home trump supporters from across the
valley joined that nationwide protest
one demonstration taking place downtown
a bit earlier today
and another one is underway now at
election headquarters up in north las
vegas
that's where we find joe moller hi there
joe
hey there brian these protests happening
throughout the day here in las vegas are
called the stop the steel protests like
you've mentioned we're outside the
election headquarters
we're staying a bit the distance away
from the group and we put the
camera in the live truck to give you a
better angle but you can take a look at
the corner here right outside of the
headquarters this is the corner of trade
and cheyenne
there's about 50 or so of people on that
corner that started about an hour ago
but again this is the stop the steel
protest
and the second one of the day a flyer
has been circulating on social media for
what they
for this event here earlier today a
caravan and protest happened in downtown
las vegas let's go ahead and get into
the video of that
at seven o'clock this morning two hours
before the start of that event cars and
trucks filled the ahern hotel
parking garage in the lot near sahara
and las vegas boulevard
hundreds made their way to the federal
courthouse downtown well into the
afternoon some people were lingering
there until after two o'clock
trump supporters hope there will be a
delay in the inauguration
of president-elect joe biden they
believe there was widespread fraud in
the election
this is how one woman explained her
reasoning for being here
and this election is fraudulent so we're
not going to put up with it we're not
going to allow it to go through
we're going to resist the election that
is fraudulent we would like to have
like the congressman and the senators
want to have a commission to investigate
it
before it is approved and we think we
have a right to that
despite multiple nevada judges and
others across the country saying there
was no widespread fraud supporters here
believe otherwise now back out here live
they're taking another look there at the
corner across the street actually there
are a number of north las vegas police
units they're preparing for this
demonstration
earlier today when we were in downtown
las vegas i spoke to a number of people
who were
leaving that event to take a little
break and then coming out here we do
expect to see
a lot more people here i know this is
the same location where a lot of
protests happen right after election day
as well but we will be out here
throughout the night
to bring you the very latest reporting
live in north las vegas joe mohler 8
news now